would you as president sit down and have
a conversation with Vladimir Putin and
Vladimir zielinski separately and
together to negotiate peace absolutely
what about Vladimir Putin
he's been in power since 2000.
so as the old adage goes power corrupts
and absolute power corrupts absolutely
uh do you think he is been corrupted by
being in power for so long if you think
of the male if you look at his mind
listen I don't know exactly
um I can't say because I just I don't
know enough about him or about you know
I might the evidence that I've seen
is that he is homicidal he kills his
enemies or poisons them
and you know the reaction I've seen to
that to hit those accusations from him
have not been to deny that but to kind
of laugh it off I think he's a dangerous
man and that of course you know
um there's probably corruption in his
regime but having said that
uh it's not our business
changed the Russian government and
anybody who thinks it's a good idea to
do regime change in Russia which has
more nuclear weapons than we do
um is I think irresponsible and you know
Vladimir Putin himself has said you know
we will not live in a world without
Russia and it was clear when he said
that that he was talking about himself
and uh and he has his hand on a button
that could bring you know Armageddon to
the entire planet so why are we messing
with this it's not our job to change
that regime and and we should be making
Fair friends with the Russians we
shouldn't be treating him as an anime
now we've pushed them into the camp with
China
that's not a good thing for our country
and by the way
you know what we're doing now does not
appear to be weakening Putin at all
Putin now you know if you believe the
the polls that are coming out of
Russia
they show him you know the most recent
polls that I've seen
um show him with that 89 popularity that
people in Russia support the war in
Ukraine
and that uh and they supported him as an
individual
so um and I understand there's problems
with polling and you know you don't know
what to believe but but the polls
consistently show that and
um and I you know it's not America's
business to be the policeman of the
world and to be changing regimes in the
world that's illegal or not we shouldn't
be breaking International laws
you know we should actually be looking
for ways
to improve relationships with Russia not
to you know not to destroy Russia not to
destroy and not to choose its leadership
for them that's up to the Russian people
not us